Now for the last method we'll write for the friend's class, at least for this
lesson. It's possible right now for John to have TJ as a friend and TJ not to
have John back. Let's write a method, removeMeanFriends, that removes all of
the friends that don't like John back. So for example, if John has friends, TJ,
Maria, Jamesha and Joe. Let's say Jamesha and Joe both like John back, but TJ
and Maria don't. So we want to remove TJ and Maria from John's friends list. So
in this case we'll start with TJ at index zero. So we'll remove TJ from the
list. Now the list gets re-indexed. To look at the next person in the list we
need to look at the zeroth person again. So we can't just have a counter
variable that we increment by one each time. We look at Maria and Maria also
doesn't like John. So we'll remove Maria and the rest of the list will get
re-indexed again. So yet again to look at the next person we have to look at
the zeroth person. We look at Jamesha and Jamesha likes John, so she should
stay in the list. We'll increment the counter and look at the next person. Joe
likes John, so we'll keep Joe in the list. So we should increment the counter
variable and look at the next person, which would be at index two. But two is
no longer a valid index. Even though it was, originally. So we're done.